what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and there have been a ton of reports and
rumors going around recently about the
cast of The Fantastic Four of course
everybody wants to know who is going to
be playing Marvel's first family in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but today
we're going to sidestep from the
Fantastic forecasting a little bit and
talk about casting news for two other
Marvel characters about to make their
MCU debut that fans are super excited
for as well and talk about how these two
could possibly enter the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what we've heard so
far and what could possibly happen the
characters we are talking about today
are Nova and the Silver Surfer now
what's kind of interesting about this is
that one of the names that was mentioned
for a role in The Fantastic Four has
been Ryan Gosling good old kin his name
has been rumored for a few different
roles now one has been Mr Fantastic the
other has been Nova and I wouldn't be
surprised if he was being considered for
the role of the Silver Surfer as well
we'll talk more about him in a bit but
he's not the actor that we'll be talking
about today that could possibly play
Nova in fact two actors that we're going
to talk about today that could play Nova
or the Silver Surfer are both kind of in
a superhero Universe right now and that
is the boys on Prime video The Voice has
turned into a really big series with a
really big following and I'm sure there
are a lot of MCU and superhero fans in
general that would love to see these
actors come to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so let's dive into who can play
Nova and who could play the Silver
Surfer from the boys franchise and if
you're new be sure to subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss out on any of
the latest videos and if you want to
enter our giveaway be sure to subscribe
and leave a comment down below for your
chance to win an Xbox series X a PS5
some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
so very recently a new leak got some
credibility many people are familiar
with 4chan it's a place where people can
post anonymously and usually we don't
really pay much attention to 4chan at
all however a part of the leak has been
proven true an anonymous user posted a
leak in April that Emma Corin was going
to be playing Cassandra Nova in Deadpool
3. yesterday this was confirmed adding
validity to this leak and what's really
interesting is that another part of this
leak said that Jensen Ackles is being
eyed for the role of Nova now if you
watch the boys you know Jensen Ackles as
Soulja Boy kind of the boys's version of
a Captain America Loosely based but a
lot of people have actually praised
Jensen Ackles performance for Soldier
Boy in the series so no doubt that he
would do a pretty decent job if he were
cast for the role of Nova now just
because Marvel Studios wants a certain
actor to play a certain role doesn't
always mean that that is what happens
perfect example is Adam Driver according
to many different insiders Adam Driver
is Wanted still currently by Marvel
Studios for the role of Mr Fantastic
Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four but
according to a recent report from some
insiders he declined the role said that
he could not connect with the character
however there have also been reports
from a couple of different insiders as
well such as Grace Randolph and Daniel
rbk they're not done with Adam Driver
they still are pursuing him trying to
get him to change his mind so that could
always happen Marvel Studios may want
Jensen Ackles to play Nova or they could
just simply get somebody who is kind of
similar to him because right now he is a
part of another superhero super villain
franchise he might not want to leave
that or he might not want to be in two
different ones at the same time however
I will say this and this is actually a
really cool fact Jensen Ackles actually
auditioned to play the role of Captain
America for the MCU before Chris Evans
was cast he obviously did not get the
role but Marvel Studios were reportedly
so impressed with him that they actually
offered him the role of Hawkeye in which
he obviously turned down because Jeremy
Renner is Hawkeye he reportedly turned
it down because of his commitment to
Supernatural at the according to a
report from indiewire a commitment that
I'm sure he would have broken for
Captain America but bottom line here is
that we know that Marvel Studios loves
him they were so impressed with him they
offered him the role of Hawkeye so it
would make sense that they would
possibly want him for another role he's
probably on Kevin feige's short list of
people he wants to play certain
characters in the MCU Now Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios has
explained his process before he says
that sometimes they meet with actors
four five six times and never find a
role for them it all depends on the
perfect role he explained this when he
talked about Jake Gyllenhaal playing
Mysterio he said that they met several
times and talked about other characters
he could possibly play until finally
Spider-Man far from home was being made
and they knew Mysterio was going to be
in the film and that they needed to cast
Mysterio and they thought bam perfect
that is the role for Jake Gyllenhaal
that has probably happened with Jensen
Ackles he has probably met with Marvel
for a few different roles and hasn't
landed on that perfect role yet but
perhaps Nova could be that perfect role
so the leak says Marvel is eye in him
for the role of Nova and the fact that
they have eyed him to play other
characters in the MCU before makes this
make sense plus like I mentioned another
part of this leak was proved accurate so
you never know this could be our Nova
and Nova is supposed to be coming in a
special presentation we haven't heard
anything really about this in a while
and since Disney and Marvel Studios are
kind of changing the way that they
produce content specifically in regards
to how much Disney plus content they
produce who knows what is going on right
now but the last we heard was that Nova
was supposed to be introduced to the MCU
in his own special presentation and then
later on appear in a different project
if we hear anything new about this of
course we'll be sure to update you and
go ahead and let us know what you would
think of Jensen ack was playing Nova in
the comments down below now as far as
the Silver Surfer is concerned there is
a possibility that another the boy star
could take the role Jack Quaid was
rumored to possibly being cast for the
Fantastic Four and recently he came out
and denied that he was playing the Human
Torch because that is what some people
were saying Marvel offered him a
contract for the Human Torch and that
could very well be possible they could
have very well offered him the role and
he could have turned it down all he said
in his tweet was hello everyone nope not
playing Johnny Storm but hey I'm
flattered now that you're here though
donate to the SAG after a foundation if
you can so what's really interesting
about this is not too long after Grace
Randolph came out and stated that so
this is interesting I hear Jack Quaid is
in Fantastic Four he's just not playing
Johnny Storm now we've heard a lot of
reports that Galactus is indeed going to
be the villain of the Fantastic Four
film so it would make sense that the
Silver Surfer would be there as his
Herald so since Jack Quaid is not going
to be playing Johnny Storm and we know
that Marvel isn't eyeing him to play Mr
Fantastic there is a possibility that he
could get the role of the Silver Surfer
this obviously is not confirmed in any
way and is speculation at this point
however it is a a very real possibility
especially if you consider what I just
mentioned about how Kevin feige goes
about meeting with actors until they
find the perfect role for them so he
could have already met with Marvel
Studios and they said hey Johnny might
not be right but maybe little Norman rad
here aka the Silver Surfer now he
doesn't actually play a superhero in the
boys so this could be his opportunity to
actually be a superhero in a huge
Universe now what's also interesting
about the Silver Surfer is he was also
supposed to debut in a Disney plus
special presentation but again things
are kind of changing at Marvel Studios
and Disney right now and who knows if
this is still actually the case we do
know Marvel Studios is going to start
producing less Disney plus content so
they might have a plan to scrap special
presentations altogether however the
ones that they have done have been
massive hits so perhaps they'll just cut
back on Disney plus series and keep
maybe one or two Disney plus special
presentations a year also the boys
official Twitter page did something kind
of funny a kind of poked fun at the
Fantastic Four casting rumors that Jack
Quade was going to play Johnny Storm of
the Fantastic Four on Prime videos
official Twitter account or X account
now they posted a picture of him and a
squad and the boys stating he's already
in a pretty Fantastic Four and the boys
official Twitter account retweeted that
they also posted this with a caption
flame on mates which is just awesome
it's really funny that the official
Twitter account for Prime video and the
boys is acknowledging and playfully
poking fun at the Fantastic forecasting
rumors and that just goes to show you
that all of these casting rumors they
get around to all of these Studios they
hear about them all but let us know what
you think about Jensen Ackles possibly
playing Nova in the MCU and Jack Quaid
possibly playing the Silver Surfer or if
there's another role in The Fantastic
Four you think will play let us know who
you think that could be in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest MCU news and be
sure to subscribe and leave a comment so
you can enter our give away you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf